yes we've got here guys we have now
officially have the iPhone 7 plus 256
jet black version it's here in this box
I promise you this is not a lie this is
real life not a fake unboxing as some of
you guys thought that my previous one
was which it actually was and I just
think that some of you guys couldn't see
very well you need to just look a little
closer he's here he's here and all of
his glory just gonna cut this plastic
right here because I know it has the
pool tab but that's not how I like to
open my boxes I want to make sure that I
make use of the knife peel this off flip
you around and prepare for the big
reveal okay let's open this up are you
ready Wow look at this the joke you guys
it's you're clearly jokes are lost on
the internet although I guess jokes are
supposed to be funny
here's our beautiful black box the jet
black version is the only one that comes
in this black box so we're feeling real
special first thing you'll notice is
your phone is greeted by some paperwork
not something that I want to read right
now my stickers are in there though oh
gosh always save your little stickers
[Music]
just take a look we just don't even want
to touch it because I'm gonna smudge it
up so much already here it is a
beautiful jet-black
256 gig iPhone
I am already smudging this up and I'm
not even touching the actual phone yet
everything guys gonna see that but I
haven't even taken off the safety paper
yet safety paper that's what we're gonna
call it
[Music]
it looks so smooth
I was really debating whether I made a
mistake getting the jet black or not it
looks really good
so before we boot up this little guy
we're gonna see what else comes in the
box I'm sure all of you already know
what comes in the box a little power
brick next up we've got the lightning
cable earbuds you know they are quite
beautiful and I may flip it over you're
gonna see you've got the lightning cable
to 3.5 millimeter headphone jack so one
of the biggest changes and the biggest
complaints that everyone is making about
the new iPhone 7 iPhone 7 plus is that
it no longer has a headphone jack so
this is kind of the first time that
Apple's really wells not the first time
they've taken away something that we
thought that we might want if we think
back to the cd-rom drive floppy drive
sure they've done something else in the
past that we've all been like what it
also comes with an extra lightning cable
so very very thoughtful because I go
through these almost like water I don't
know where the lightning cables go it's
like socks probably hanging out together
somewhere so here's all of our items
that come in the box
okay well can we can we just take a peek
I'm not sure if you can tell it is so
freakin smudgy already it's unbelievable
it's like it's like a factory of smudge
I've touched it for maybe maybe 2
minutes setting up touch ID I'll
continue I'll do it so it's really weird
pressing the home button now because
it's not an actual button so it kind of
gives you that feedback and sensation
that you are pressing a button but it's
not an actual button so other than the
dual camera these antenna bands are no
longer here so it's a much cleaner look
which I am into so here's the different
colors man I really should have got a
matte black let's take a quick little
look here at the lightning cable and the
3.5 millimeter jack let's open this up
so this does come with your phone which
for most people if you do have a 3.5
millimeter headphone jacks that you plan
on using you can just keep this clipped
to your headphones so it's really not
that big of a deal those people who are
making it it's super small it isn't
chapter so here's some headphones that I
always use it's super simple look at
this plug it in like so actually not
even that big of a deal at all you can
buy another one of these the Apple store
so you can just plug this into your aux
cable so you'll still be able to pass
the aux it's possible I get this same as
I'm going off my desk because making me
very uncomfortable lightning cables -
3.5 milimeter - headphones the world is
right everything is awesome here's our
lightning cable headphones they're
basically these same exact headphones
that usually come with every other Apple
device these do not work for me at all
they really they do not stay in my ears
very well look it already fell out okay
one of the other huge updates in the
iPhone 7 plus that is not in the iPhone
7 is the dual lens so there's one
telephoto lens and the other one is
basically the same lens that is in the
iPhone 6s so with this it'll allow you
to get better close-up shots so there's
two different modes it'll determine
between which one you need to use so
right now I'm going to take a photo in
the 1x right here this changes from 1 X
2 to X now I'm gonna take a photo with
the 2x of the camera that I'm filming
that and then I'm gonna zoom all the way
in and take a picture with the 10x zoom
so as you can see here this is my 10x
photo this is my 2x photo and this is my
1x photo looks pretty good I mean I'm
pretty impressed so if you guys haven't
picked up a phone yet and you don't plan
on putting a case on it I don't think I
recommend getting the jet black it's
super smudgy I mean well actually why
would you even get it anyway because if
you're gonna put a case on it no one's
gonna even know you have the jet black
anyway I ordered a white case and a
black case to go with it so that it will
kind of sort of match to the new ceramic
watch they'll send an unboxing of the
ceramic watch so if you guys want to go
check that out I'll put a link in the
description and a card here so you can
take a peek this is the first time that
I've got a black phone in a really long
time
most of my devices are the silver the
one thing that kind of drives me a
little bit crazy about the white phones
is the front
in this one it looks like a completely
just flushed color whereas the white
stands out so much I also use privacy
screens on my phone so the privacy
screens usually make the edge of your
phone black anyway it's them all cracked
but I don't think it's gonna fit I feel
like it's a little bit different it
looks like the front-facing camera is a
little bit moved over and this at the
top the speaker is a little bit wider so
far and the little experience that I've
had with the seven plus it is a much
nicer phone the back does look really
really nice
other than the smudges one of the last
upgrades that I didn't mention yet is
the flash it actually has four LED
flashes now so it's kind of hard to see
but before there was - there was one on
the top one on the bottom so now there's
four I'm sure you guys have taken so
many photos with your iPhone flash and
they've looked pretty terrible in the
past but hopefully this will help
alleviate that before it even takes a
photo it kind of tries to sense what the
lighting situation is and will try to
adjust on the fly from what I've even
seen in the previous phone having the
dual flash made a huge difference so I'm
hoping that this quad flash will make a
difference as well thanks for watching
guys have some more fun videos for you
coming up soon and we will be back on
track with cooking videos tech tuesdays
and random vlogs coming at you real soon
but for now i'm gonna go like forgot
that i wanted to show you guys the size
differences between the iPad iPad pro
and do the seven plus just in case you
don't know what that looks like
cuz there it is I'll see you guys soon
bye I'm also left-handed so I wear
watches on the right so after I set it
up I'm gonna have to swap it this way so
that the it is actually upside down
because at the
crown will be here and then I end up
having to also so this
Wow